okay we're live right now 109 it's 114
we're not live anymore guys it's my
birthday
no one's here because it's 1:00 in the
morning California time look who's in
the room with us yes
we got one like it's my birthday we had
a giant party Oh Shia party now and now
I'm gonna call it a night I'm gonna what
time is it now we got four minutes to
livestream people four minutes
oh look at all these people saying happy
birthday I've lived for your comments I
live for your approval that's all I care
about
[Laughter]
I love how my girlfriend's like this
secret girlfriend she's in the bedroom
with Alex she does exist so maybe she's
not she's in the room it's not Anita
ready to stop mortal soul says you're
deaf oh truck you're drunk you mother F
[Laughter]
you two been there at pockle is the
internet that ever [ __ ] swear there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Stacey was gay I don't know which was
talked about the guys Stacy's dating
Ryan with his life Mansu from Arkansas
Ryan yeah he was he was he was Rocky he
was like I don't know what this party
Stacy's the dude stations daily I don't
know where was this party but I'm gonna
[ __ ] jam at the rock man and sing and
play guitar so he was great alright so
we're at 2 minutes and 36 seconds at 5
minute mark I'm hitting the finish
button
I love Kyle great
this guy's black metal vegan you promote
people yeah
follow Stefan Mach whoa
Cara man Boyce's drunk people are
annoying as [ __ ]
alright we got a minute and 20 seconds
Jana Baker just give two bucks dude
that's the greatest birthday present any
man could ask for more bodies the best
thing in the world
Bob I'm gonna have a shot give it a ben
affleck batman
dude okay
hey we got 68 like let's get one more
like 69 it's a sex dumper all right I'm
gonna answer one question for you guys
that I'm done with the live here ask one
question first question that comes up
gets an answer tubes
YouTube don't worry guys this videos not
monetized because people don't like the
youtubers who like do things that are
monetized yeah don't do things for you
just do for you dudes I want you to
dedicate your life to make you videos if
you make money you're a seller oh [ __ ]
are you gay no my house am i I'm 27
years old
27 guys I said I already live stream for
5 minutes and 40 seconds so I gotta go
now but thank you all for being here so
late and no I don't take medication all
right panic three dollars did dude keep
your monies is blowing in you guys are
pretty much paying for them
[Applause]
this is not great happy alright I gotta
go much love Mary
say hi to Mel Gibson